[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
eight years after the crime jury
selection finally begins as a former
police captain stands trial for murder
and the men convicted in the death of
ahmad armory stand trial for federal
hate crimes plus the nfl racial
discrimination lawsuit the nfl has a
decision do they want to go down that
road
that long lengthy road or do they want
to stop for a moment
and listen what commissioner roger
goodell has to say but first our lives
were
completely destroyed emotional victim
impact statements given and a verdict
handed down in the trial of the waffle
house shooter law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin guilty on all counts that's the
verdict a tennessee jury reached after
just four hours of deliberation in the
trial of waffle house shooter travis
ranking
in 2018 travis ranking opened fire at a
nashville waffle house four people were
killed and others injured the trial was
delayed for months as ranking was
treated for schizophrenia the defense
argued insanity claiming rankin believed
god himself told him to go to the waffle
house that night and that everyone
inside was a government agent the
prosecution countered saying ranking
knew right from wrong
on friday a tennessee jury read ranking
his fate
count one
we the jury unanimously find travis j
ranking
for the offense of premeditated first
degree murder
guilty
on saturday a jury sentenced ranking to
life in prison without the possibility
of parole after hearing heartbreaking
victim impact statements
i've always been
somebody that they say
is unbreakable
because no matter what our family has
been through
i will always be the one to bring our
family up
this has broken me
not just my spirit
not just my family
but also my mind
it has been hard
for me
to get up every day
and to go on to think
i wake up every day
with just a little bit of hope
that everything that has happened
is a dream
and then i wake up
and everything
will be
we'll be fine
but it isn't
and he truly is
gone
every morning i wake up with the same
thought
my baby is gone
every morning
before i even get out of my bed
i relive that night in my head
every morning
i feel that unbearable sense of loss
and sorrow
i miss him
the pain is so great
that some days i'm not sure i can't even
open my eyes
i didn't lose my son achilles
he was taken from me
taken from my family
ripped
from us
a judge will decide whether rankings for
guilty counsel run consecutively or
concurrently and what sentence he faces
for the four other counts that
sentencing is scheduled for may 6.
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernardo villalona and terry
austin renard it took the jury just four
hours to find ranking was guilty
regardless of his mental health status
what do you think brought them there
i think brought this jury to determine
that travis rankin definitely knew the
difference between right and wrong is
that the prosecution took careful and
meticulous measures to bring out to this
jury each action that travis ranking
took for example he knew to run from the
location he knew to hide from the
location he knew especially i think the
most moving part of the closing
arguments is when the prosecutor one by
one put the cartridges into the magazine
of that assault rifle and every time he
did that it was a conscious decision of
them knowing the difference between
right and wrong
now terry the judge will decide if
ranking sentence will run consecutively
or concurrently what do you think will
happen and why
you know from a technical standpoint
brian it's not going to make a
difference obviously life is life but
from a philosophical standpoint whether
you have concurrent or consecutive that
sends a message and the main two
functions of this punishment is to deter
and it's for retribution and i think if
the judge has listened to all of the
evidence particularly the medical
evidence and he looks at those facts
like bernard just mentioned i think at
the end of the day he is going to give
consecutive sentences yeah i would even
add on to that as well the victim impact
statements as well as just the
heinousness of this act i would
definitely if i was a betting man i
would say that consecutive sentence
rather than concurrent sentences will be
what's here but i agree with you terry
it's philosophical at this point he's
probably going to spend the rest of his
life in jail and die behind bars thank
you both moving on to an update out of
connecticut as the naacp asked the
department of justice to investigate
following the deaths of two black women
lauren smithfield and brendaly rawls
both died on december 12th of last year
in bridgeport connecticut families for
both 23 year old smithfield and 53 year
old rawls say they were not notified of
their deaths by bridgeport police while
smithfield's death was ruled an
accidental overdose the cause and manner
of death are both still under determined
for roles critics say the death
investigations were botched based on
systemic racism two detectives involved
in the investigation of smith fields
have since been placed on administrative
leave pending an internal affairs
investigation
still ahead on law and crime daily the
men convicted in the death of a mod
arbory now face federal hate crime
charges
but first the latest development in the
nfl discrimination lawsuit what
commissioner roger goodell has to say
about accusations of racial
discrimination
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
commissioner of the nfl is speaking out
about diversity and hiring days after a
former coach claimed in a lawsuit
there's discrimination in hiring law and
crimes angie levy is here with somewhat
surprising development from the league
brian the nfl had previously released a
statement saying that brian flores's
claims in that class-action lawsuit were
without merit but then over the weekend
nfl commissioner roger goodell
said in a memo that the league's efforts
to hire a more diverse field of
candidates or to hire more diverse
coaches have been unacceptable that memo
first surfaced on twitter after former
miami dolphins coach brian flores filed
that lawsuit last week claiming he was
only interviewed for the coaching job
with the new york giants to fulfill the
rooney rule which requires that two
minorities be interviewed for positions
flores released a text message with that
lawsuit from patriots coach bill
belichick that he received days before
his interview with the giants
congratulating him on getting the job
but the problem was that text message
was meant for brian dable a white coach
who ended up getting the job i spoke
with flores attorney who said the goal
of their lawsuit is to start a
conversation with the nfl about making
meaningful changes
what brian flores did here took
extreme active coverage coverage
and sacrifice because he's putting
his future coaching career
at risk
certainly colin kaepernick who protested
racial injustice never got a job in the
nfl again just by clearly being
qualified at the most important position
on the field
um
but the nfl and its owners have an
opportunity here
um because he's in the running for two
he he's he was just interviewed for two
coaching jobs coach flores the saints
and the texans
and they have an opportunity
to show true leadership
the same type of leadership that coach
flores showed in filing the case
commissioner goodell said in that same
memo that came out over the weekend that
the league will hire experts in
diversity equity and inclusion to look
at the league's hiring practices brian
thanks again jeanette let's bring back
criminal defense attorney bernardo
villalona and terry austin to discuss
the latest legal battles with the nfl
terry i'm not questioning the sincerity
of goodell's memo but if the nfl starts
adjusting policies does that take some
heat off the league and maybe put it on
to the individual teams
i don't think so listen i think the heat
should be on the league and the teams as
a former diversity and employment law
specialist i can tell you changing
policies does nothing unless you do more
it doesn't change the culture of that
organization you have to have a series
of concerted actions and you have to do
that especially if you're seeing a
pattern and practice of discrimination
you have to have tone at the top and
listen as far as i'm concerned nfl
commissioner goodall he has been
relatively silent since this memo so it
means that he has done too little and
it's a little bit too late
now bernardo flores found out he wasn't
part of this group text message when it
seems like his 69 year old friend
accidentally texted him are we going to
see belichick deposed before this
lawsuit gets resolved
i definitely see him being deposed if
anything they probably will try to
settle even before he gets the polls
because how much information could
belichick have ken belichick exposed the
entire nfl so i think they may try to
keep him quiet and just settle this
quietly so no one has to get the post
yeah and don't forget uh belichick used
to coach at the giants and both brian
dabo and brian flores was his assistant
so if anyone's to know what's going on
in the giants probably belichick and
jeanette after roger goodell's statement
came out news broke about another nfl
coaching hire right
that's right brian and you know it came
from the miami dolphins that is the team
that fired brian flores back on january
10th of this year just last month well
they have now hired mike mcdaniel to be
their new head coach it's a four-year
deal and he comes to them from the 49ers
where he worked as the offensive
coordinator and mcdaniel
actually identifies as multi-racial so
he is now just the fourth coach right
now with the nfl who is a minority brian
thank you for that update and then
update in the new hire for coaches in
the nfl we finally have some good news
to share with you out of colorado a dog
is safe and alive after an suv caught on
fire with him trapped inside a douglas
county deputy came to the rescue and
saved the pup
it happened last week when deputy
michael grigorik was called to the scene
for a car fire when he got there a man
was throwing something at the back
window he turned out to be the owner of
the car and the dog named hank deputy
grigorik used his retractable baton to
break the windows out of the car hank's
owner attempted to pull him out through
the back window the smoke was
overpowering so deputy grigorik stepped
in and pulled the dog to safety
thankfully a neighbor is a vet and was
able to check hank soon after he was
rescued
coming up on law and crime daily why has
it taken eight years for a former
florida police captain to be tried for
murder plus all three men plead not
guilty to federal hate crime charges in
the death of a armory it's day one of
jury selection after this
[Music]
welcome back federal court is back in
sachinite minnesota after cobin 19
diagnosis put the trial on hold for the
three ex-officers charged in the death
of george floyd on monday court resumed
for two tao thomas lane and jay
alexander king who are charged with
violating george floyd's rights as
convicted killer derek chovin knelt on
his neck last week a federal judge
announced one of the defendants tested
positive for covid 19 and that court
proceedings will be put on hold while
the defendant's name was not released
both king and tao were in the courtroom
at the time of the announcement lane was
not on monday court resumed with
testimony from a lung specialist
also in federal court jury selection
begins for the three men convicted in
the death of ahmad arbury father and son
gregory and travis michael and neighbor
william roddy bryan face kidnapping and
hate crime charges for aubry's 2020
death at the time the 25 year old
unarmed black man was going for a run
near his brunswick georgia home travis
and gregory mcmichael followed along in
a pickup truck claiming they believed
aubry was responsible for a string of
robberies in their neighborhood travis
mcmichael eventually shot and killed
aubry and brian recorded most of the
incident on his cell phone last fall all
three men were convicted in aubrey's
death both mcmichaels were sentenced to
life in prison without the possibility
parole plus 20 years while brian must
serve at least 30 years before he's
eligible for parole last week a federal
judge denied plea deals for both
mcmichaels all three men have pled not
guilty to federal charges
criminal defense attorney bernardo
villalona and co-host terry austin are
back as jury selections for the
mcmichaels and brian begin terry travis
and michael testified in the last trial
do you think any of them will tell
jurors they'll testify and if so who
well i'll tell you this based on the
guilty verdicts that travis mcmichael
got and remember he got that felony
murder and he got the malice murder so i
think they're going to think twice
before putting him back on the stand
he's going to have a very difficult time
explaining in this case his racial slurs
on social media and you better believe
those are going to get introduced so i
don't think we'll see him i also don't
think we're going to see gregory
mcmichael get up on that stand because
he's not going to want to explain any
sort of derogatory comments he made over
the body of ahmad avery so that's a no
and i think maybe if we see anyone we
might see roddy bryant get up on that
stand but if they decide to do that i
don't think they're going to signal that
to the jury because what they really
want to do is hold their cards close to
their best and that way they can make a
decision based on whatever the evidence
might be yeah i think that would be the
smarter route but maybe like you said uh
brian would get up on the stand but i've
heard at least in the state trial that
his attorney kevin goff said that brian
isn't the sharpest tool in the shed i
don't think that's the best thing to say
about your client but i don't know maybe
he'll take the stand bernardo different
charges same defendants what's the
defense here in federal court for these
three men
well well they're going to have to
actually show what the prosecution has
to prove that the motive for actually
chasing ahmad rv down the motive for
stopping him the motive for hunting them
was because of his race that they
deliberately tried to take away deprive
the rights of ahmad arbory based on
being a black man so in terms of what is
the defense going to do to try to rebut
that because in the end they have no
burden of proof they do not have to put
up any evidence or the burden is on the
prosecution i don't know who's going to
testify i can tell you this that
regardless travis michael did testify at
the state trial and it's possible even
without him testifying that the
prosecution can use his testimony from
the state trial and put it into evidence
during this federal trial and let's see
how that plays out
yeah i think you
take his previous testimony you take the
the comments that terry was alluding to
as well i agree i don't think traffic
michael takes a stand but i would love
to see it a second time it'd be
interesting to see how it plays out in
this the federal case
when we come back eight years after the
death of chad olson the man accused of
his murder will finally stand trial jury
selection begins as former police
captain curtis reeves is charged with
second-degree murder that's next on law
and crime daily
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily it's
one of the longest criminal cases in u.s
history nearly a decade after a man was
fatally shot at a florida movie theater
the case is finally going to trial jury
selection began on monday in the murder
trial for former police captain curtis
reeves the man prosecutors say is
responsible for the deadly shooting
reeves is accused of killing chad olson
after the two got into an argument
because olson was on his cell phone
during movie previews reeves claims he
shot olson in self-defense testifying at
a failed stand your ground hearing in
2017 that olson threw popcorn at him and
said olson was getting ready to punch
him a judge ruled against his stand your
ground claims so now the case heads to a
jury trial reeves faces a second degree
murder charge and has been on house
arrest since the shooting jury selection
was difficult monday morning with many
prospective jurors being excused for
having knowledge of the case a panel of
six jurors along with four alternates
will be chosen also's wife is expected
to testify
bernardo let's get right to the heart of
this case can popcorn regardless of how
much butter because i know that can be a
factor and a cell phone i guess because
that came into part of this be deadly
force enough for you to shoot someone
and claim self-defense
i mean the only deadly force i see from
the prop from the popcorn is probably
clogging up my arteries but aside from
that i don't see it as deadly force what
we're talking about here especially when
we're talking about that this man was a
former police department captain so if
anything there's a higher burden in
terms of him being and reasonable fear
for his life because he's been in
situations where possibly a gun was
pointed to him or he's running to the
line of fire but come on here a cell
phone some popcorn inside a movie
theater it just wasn't reasonable for
him to use that deadly force against
this unarmed man
now i agree with you i had to look this
up it's 2014 so i'm thinking around that
time that's the iphone 6. if it's not
like my father's cell phone that like he
had to hold like this because that could
be deadly force but if it's just a
regular iphone 6 i would agree with you
i think we're gonna need some more facts
on this case as it plays out terry this
will be a six person jury instead of 12.
is that unusual is that like how are we
supposed to read into that
you know
brian that is very unusual but it's not
unheard of defendants almost always have
in a criminal case anyway 12 jurors
because under the constitution that's
the way it's been interpreted but there
have been supreme court cases that have
said you can have a six-member jury it
is still constitutional because there
are a couple of things that they are
looking for one you want to make sure
there's a group deliberation and here
whether it's 6 or 12 there's still a big
enough group to be deliberating the
other thing they want to do with the
jury is they want to make sure that
those jurors are protected they're
promoting the fact that there's safety
in numbers you don't want just one or
two people making such a huge decision
and the other factor the third factor is
you want to make sure you have a cross
section of the community as long as you
have all of those things you can have
six jurors and one of the things the
judge is doing here is making sure that
we have at least four alternatives and
they're doing that because of covet 19
obviously if one or two of those jurors
get sick then they can have several
other jurors to take the place so i
think this jury is going to work out
just fine
yeah we'll see how it plays out it seems
like a little bit of confidence from the
defense that they only need six rather
than twelve we'll see how that plays out
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you